Hey everyone, this is Dr. Marcon and this is chapter 20 on blood vessels.
So what I'm going to do is I'm actually going to break up blood vessels into regions.
I'm going to talk about the general characteristics of blood vessels and then for this unit I'm
going to be talking about the blood supply to the head, neck, upper limb as well as the
thoracic region.
And then the next unit will talk about the blood supply to the abdomen as well as the
lower limb.
So we have three types of blood vessels that transport blood in the body.
We have arteries, arteries, capillaries, and veins.
So arteries carry blood away from the heart.
And then we have arterioles.
These are the smallest type of arteries.
We have capillaries.
These are the smallest blood vessels.
And from the capillaries we'll have venules.
Venules will receive blood from capillaries and then the veins will receive blood from
the venules and then these veins will transport blood back towards the heart.
General structure of blood vessels is composed of three layers or tunics.
The inner most layer is the tunica intima.
The tunica intima is the inner most tunic contains endothelium, which is made up of a
simple squamous epithelium.
And usually vessels that are greater than 1 millimeter will also have a sub endothelial
layer, so sub meaning below, so this is a layer below the endothelium.
The second layer, this middle layer is the tunica media.
When you think tunica media, I think middle, muscular layer, the tunica media is made up
of sheets of smooth muscle.
Contraction of this muscle causes vasoconstriction.
Relaxation of this layer causes vasodilation.
Remember when we talked about what smooth muscle does and how it lines blood vessels
as well as the hollow organs of the body.
The outer most layer is the tunica externa, also known as the tunica adventisia.
This layer is composed of connective tissue.
And finally, we have a centralized space called the lumen.
The lumen is a central blood-filled space of a blood vessel.
And here we see the generalized structures of arteries, veins, and capillaries.
So arteries, again, being the blood vessels that carry blood away from the heart.
We see the three layers.
We see the tunica intima with the inner most layer, the endothelium.
Below that layer is that sub endothelial layer.
And then around that would be the internal elastic membrane.
The tunica media is made up of smooth muscle as well as elastic fibers that we talked about
in unit one.
There is an external elastic membrane.
And then finally, an outer most tunica externa or tunica adventisia made up of collagen fibers.
We then have a blood supply or the vasovasorium layer of these blood vessels.
And of course, there is that centralized space called the lumen.
Now both arteries and veins do have the same generalized structure.
However, there are distinct differences between arteries and veins, which we'll get into.
One of the most distinctive differences, of course, is the thickness of that tunica media,
that middle muscular layer.
We know that arteries have a thicker tunica media.
Also another main difference is that some veins do have valves within their lumen.
And these valves help prevent the back flow of blood.
So then we get down to the capillaries, the capillaries being the smallest vessels.
And they're usually made up of one layer of endothelium.
And they're very porous, meaning they allow for cells to go through and also allow for
gas exchange.
So here we see arteries usually carrying oxygenated blood away from the heart to the rest of the
system and then down to the capillary level where we'll have gas exchange.
And then deoxygenated blood goes into the vaniels and then into the veins to carry deoxygenated
blood or carbon dioxide rich blood back to the heart.
Here we see a slide of a typical artery and vein.
Again, we can see that distinctive tunica media, that very thick tunica media within an artery,
a lot thicker compared to the thinner walled vein.
And if you get to actually handle cadaver sections, you'll feel that arteries are a lot
springier, a lot kind of thicker compared to the thinner walled veins.
Now we have different types of arteries.
The largest arteries are called elastic arteries and they range in diameter from 2.5 centimeter
to 1 centimeter.
This includes the aorta.
We know the air is one of the largest arteries that carries blood away from the heart.
So the aorta and its major branches are examples of elastic arteries.
These are sometimes called conducting arteries.
And these types of arteries have a very high elastin content.
So a high amount of elastic connected tissue that helps dampen that surge of blood pressure
and kind of gives the artery that recoil characteristic to allow for the pumping of
blood to the rest of the system.
So we see this familiar slide.
We see the layers, the different layers of an elastic artery, particularly.
This could be the aorta.
This is the aorta actually.
So we have that centralized lumen.
We have that innermost layer which is the tunica intima and then this very thick middle muscular.
This is the tunica media with a high elastin content.
And then the outermost layer being the tunica externa made up of connective tissue also called
the tunica adventitia.
The next type of artery are the muscular or distributing arteries.
These arteries actually lie distal to the elastic arteries.
And their diameters range from 1 centimeter to 0.3 millimeters.
These include most named arteries.
Like most arteries, the tunica media is thick.
Some unique features about the muscular or distributing arteries.
They have an internal and external elastic laminae.
So the internal elastic laminae forms the outer layer of the tunica intima while the external
elastic membrane or external elastic laminae forms the outer layer of the tunica media.
Again, these elastic membranes in addition to the elastin found within the tunica media
will help to dampen that pulsatile pressure produced by the heartbeat.
And on this next slide, we can see an example of muscular or distributing artery.
Again, we have the lumen and we have the tunica intima and that tunica intima has an outer
layer of the internal elastic membrane.
We have this thick tunica media that contains the elastin fibers also that middle muscular
layer and external to that layer.
We have an external elastic membrane.
And here we see the outermost layer that tunica, externa, or tunica and ventisha.
Arterials are the smallest of the arteries.
Their diameters range from 0.3 millimeters to 10 micrometers.
The larger arterials possess all three layers or all three tunics.
And the diameter of arterials is controlled by local factors in the tissues, as well as
the sympathetic nervous system that fight or flight response.
And here we see small arterials, some containing all three layers, usually the larger ones contain
all three layers.
So we can see the lumen.
We see that inner tunica intima made up of endothelium, and we see that middle layer,
the tunica media, and then the outermost layer, the tunica externa.
Now, capillaries are the smallest blood vessels.
Their diameter ranges anywhere from 8 to 10 micrometers or microns, and usually just
a large enough for red blood cells to pass through in a single file.
Now we have slight specific functions of capillaries.
For example, capillary network in the lungs, this is where oxygen enters blood.
We have diffusion exchange of gases, so oxygen will enter the blood, whereas carbon dioxide
will leave the blood so that it can be exhaled out by the lungs.
Within the small intestines, capillaries are important because they receive digestive nutrients
when we break down our food into smaller molecules, these capillaries that will receive the smaller
molecules to be transported to our tissues.
Within the endocrine glands, our capillaries help pick up hormones that are secreted by
endocrine glands.
In the kidneys, the capillaries are responsible for removal of nitrogynous waste products
formed by the kidneys.
And here we see a capillary whose diameter is just large enough for red blood cells to
kind of pass through in a single file.
We have different types of capillaries.
We have continuous capillaries.
This is the most common type of capillary that occurs in most organs.
We have tight junctions and desmosomes that help join epithelial cells.
We also have intercellular claps, and these are gaps of unjoined membranes that allow
small molecules in and out of capillaries.
So here we see a continuous capillary, and it's the least permeable of the capillaries,
but is the most common.
So here we see the different structures that make up the continuous capillary.
We have the intercellular claps between the endothelial cells.
We have tight junctions between these cells.
And we can see within the lumen of the capillary red blood cell.
Finestrated capillaries, these are capillaries that are joined by tight junctions and desmosomes.
They have pores in their endotheliums, pores to allow molecules to pass through, or gases
to pass through.
So fenestrated capillaries occur where high rates of exchange occur, for example, in the
intestines with the exchange of digested nutrients.
The glomeruli of kidneys where we have capillaries that help receive nitrogenous waste products
and then endocrine glands where we have secretion of hormones.
So here we see a fenestrated capillary.
Again, we have a large fenestration, also known as pores.
We can see these pores between the endothelial cells to help increase permeability of molecules
or gases.
So occurs in areas of active absorption or filtration such as the kidney and small intestine.
Now sinusoids are wide leaky capillaries found in some organs that are usually porous
or fenestrated.
The intracellular clefs are wide open and these occur in bone marrow and spleen.
We heard about sinusoids in the spleen before.
So sinusoids have a large diameter and a twisted course.
So here we see large endothelial clefs or intracellular clasps between the endothelial
cells and again they are joined by tight junctions and we can see that there is a bit of an incomplete
basement membrane.
So very large and porous and these are the most permeable and occurs in special locations
such as the liver, the bone marrow and the spleen.
So with regards to permeability, there are four roots into and out of capillaries.
We have direct diffusion of molecules.
We also have roots through the intracellular clefs, those spaces between the endothelial
cells.
We also have permeability through cytoplasmic vesicles and then through pores or fenestrations.
Now we have areas that have capillaries that are of low permeability, specifically the
blood-brain barrier, within the blood-brain barrier, capillaries have complete tight junctions
and there are no intracellular clefs present.
And only the vital molecules can pass through so it's a very highly selective transport mechanism.
However, does not provide a barrier against oxygen, carbon dioxide, which is important
for gas exchange and some anesthetics, so some anesthesia that provide that numb feeling
so that we can perform surgery or some sort of procedure without harming our patient or
causing our patient pain.
Capillary beds are a network of capillaries running through tissues.
We have structures called pre-capillary sphincters that help regulate the flow of blood into the
tissues.
We know that structures such as tendons and ligaments are poorly vascularized and even
epithelium and cartilage are a vascular, meaning they don't have their own blood supply but
instead receive nutrients from nearby connected tissue.
So here is an example of an anatomy bed.
We can see where gas exchange occurs, so the capillaries deliver oxygen to the tissues
and then the distal end of the capillary bed will receive carbon dioxide, will exchange
the carbon dioxide and then transfer the deoxygenated blood to the venules and then to the veins.
But again, we do have these structures called pre-capillary sphincters that kind of regulate
the flow, the blood flow through the capillaries.
So here we can see a terminal arterial feeding into the capillary bed bringing oxygenated
blood to the capillary bed and then we have the post-capillary venule which will carry
deoxygenated blood away from the capillary bed.
So almost all tissues contain these capillary beds that again allow for the delivery of
oxygen to tissues and then the carrying away of waste products as well as carbon dioxide
away from tissues to go back towards the heart.
When we have relaxation of these pre-capillaries, we can see blood passing through all the capillaries
within this capillary bed.
So we have the true capillaries that allow for that gas exchange of oxygen and then carbon
dioxide.
However, when these pre-capillary sphincters close or tighten, there's only blood flow
that goes through this structure called the met arterial.
So it actually bypasses the true capillaries within the capillary bed.
And this occurs when the tissue has lower oxygen demands, such as when nearby tissue
cells already have adequate oxygen, so the pre-capillary sphincters will close off the
true capillaries and force the blood through that met arterial again and flows straight
through into the thoroughfarer channel and then into the post-capillary venule.
So now we're going to talk about venous vessels, venous vessels.
So veins, the definition, basically they conduct blood from the capillaries toward the heart.
Blood pressure is much lower in veins compared to arteries.
We talked about venules being the first vein that kind of receives blood from the capillary
bed.
So we have venules that are the smallest veins and their diameters can range anywhere from
8 to 100 microns or micrometers.
The smallest venules we talked about are called post-capillary venules and venules will eventually
join to form larger veins.
Because we talked about having structural differences compared to arteries, there are
lumens, the space within the blood vessel or within the vein are a lot larger compared
to arteries.
65% of blood that we have in our bodies are contained in the veins at any given time.
We know that the tunica external, that outermost layer, is actually thicker compared to arteries.
But we also know that veins have a less elastin in their walls and these walls are thinner
compared to the arteries.
And this table in your book, Table 20.1, just basically is a summary of the anatomy of blood
vessels and it compares the average lumen diameter and wall thickness of the different
types of vessels and then it will show you the relative tissue makeup within the endothelium
elastic tissues smooth muscles as well as fibrous collagenous tissues.
So I would definitely just to kind of summarize the general characteristics of the blood vessels
that we talked about in the previous slides use this table to study.
So here we see elastic artery, the largest of the arteries and then going down to the
muscular artery and the different characteristics of the two.
And then we have arterials and capillaries, then we'll have the venules, the smallest
of the veins, and the smallest one we talked about was post-capillary venule receiving
deoxygenic blood from the capillary bed, which will then feed into veins.
So we can see distinct differences of the tissue makeup between veins and arteries.
So make sure you study this table to kind of get an idea of the different characteristics.
Now we have specific mechanisms to help counteract low venous pressure within veins.
We have structures called valves and valves are not contained in all veins but they are
contained in some veins, particularly in the limbs.
Vals help prevent backflow of blood.
Valves are not located in the veins of the thoracic and abdominal cavities.
We also have the skeletal muscle pump.
So our muscles press against the thin walled veins to help allow for the flow of blood.
We can actually see it in this next slide.
We can see how the contraction of skeletal muscle kind of pushes the blood through our
veins.
And we can see that the valves will help prevent the backflow of blood.
So vessels will interconnect to form vascular and nastomosis.
Nastomosis are just connections between these vessels.
Organs will receive blood from more than one arterial source.
We'll have neighboring arteries that form an arterial anastomosis which helps provide
collateral channels.
So if we have tissue that has a blood supply, it will have a main artery that gives its
blood supply, however, will have collateral arteries that also help give blood supply
to that tissue so that if we have one of the arteries kind of cut off, we'll have other
arteries also kind of making up for that cut off artery to provide additional blood supply
to that tissue.
So provide collateral channels is one of the characteristics of arterial anastomosis.
Veins will anastomosis more frequently than arteries.
So we talked about the pulmonary circulation.
The first great vessel that we talked about is the pulmonary trunk.
You know the pulmonary trunk is that a large vessel that will leave the right ventricle
and the blood has to pass through the pulmonary semilunar valves.
The pulmonary trunk will divide into right and left pulmonary arteries.
Again, these pulmonary arteries are the only arteries in the body that transport deoxygenated
blood or oxygen poor blood.
It still fits the definition of an artery in which these are vessels that carry blood
away from the heart.
So from the pulmonary arteries, blood will be transported to the lungs where it will
get reoxygenated, will have a gas exchange occurring at the capillary level, and then
the reoxygenated blood will be transported to the superior and inferior pulmonary veins
on the right and left side.
These structures, these vessels will carry oxygen and blood back to the heart via the
left atrium.
The vessels of the pulmonary circuit, they have thinner walls compared to systemic vessels,
and the max arterial pressure is lower in the pulmonary circuit.
So they have thinner walls to allow for maximum gas exchange, and we can actually see that
in this next slide, and we'll talk more about this when we get to the respiratory system.
So we see that the smallest structures within the lungs are abioli.
These are sort of like sac structures that look like kind of grape clusters, and they're
very thin mold, and we can see gas exchange occurring between the abioli and the pulmonary
capillary.
So carbon dioxide is exchanged for oxygen.
Carbon dioxide will travel back into the abioli, whereas oxygen will travel into the pulmonary
capillary.
Again, this gas exchange allows for the exhalation of carbon dioxide and the inhalation of oxygen
to be transported to the tissues of the body, the tissues and organs of our body.
Now with the systemic circulation, again, we have systemic arteries that will carry oxygenated
blood away from the heart.
We know that the aorta is the largest artery in the body, and the aorta receives blood
from the left ventricle.
So here we see a diagram of the major arteries of the systemic circulation.
We can see that from the heart, blood will be pumped from the left ventricle to the aorta
to go to the rest of the body.
The branches of the aortic arch, giving blood supply to the head, neck and the upper limbs,
and then the descending aorta or the thoracic aorta given blood supply to the thoracic structures.
And then once it passes through that diaphragm, that muscle that separates the thorax from
the abdomen, it becomes the abdominal aorta, which will then give blood supply to organs
with the abdomen, and then bifurcate into the iliac arteries, the common iliac arteries
right and left, giving blood supply to the structures within the pelvis.
And then once it passes that inguina canal, it becomes the femoral artery, all the way
down to the tibular and fibular arteries as well as the arteries within the foot, so giving
blood supply to the lower limbs.
That's the basic general idea, and we're going to break these down, break the arteries and
the veins down into regions so we can get a better sense of the specific blood supply
of the different parts of the body.
But this very small structure or a very small diagram, which you'll also find in your book,
are actually arteries that we use to palpate a pulse.
So here we'll have pulse points within our body.
So within our head we have that superficial temporal artery where we can get a temporal
pulse.
We have the facial artery located kind of anterior to the ear.
One of the most common pulse points is the common carotid artery within the neck when
we are performing CPR.
We want to get a pulse within the neck and we are palpating the common carotid artery.
Another artery that's very important is the brachial artery.
When we are taking blood pressure with our sphinctmoanometers, this is the artery that
is occluded when we are pumping up our sphinctmoanometers.
And then releasing the valve to hear the blood rushing back into this artery, the brachial
artery to obtain a blood pressure amount, our systolic and diastolic blood pressure.
And then our radial artery, which we find at the base of the thumb, also important for
taking heart rate.
Another important artery is the femoral artery, which we can find in the inguinal region or
the top part of the thigh.
The pupilidial artery right behind our knee.
This can be palpated also to find a pulse.
If we have, for example, a patient that is an amputee that doesn't have any arms and
we want to palpate a pulse within their lower limbs.
We can find it in the pupilidial artery.
Also the posterior tibular artery is an artery that we can find a pulse.
And more common is the dorsalis pedis artery, this artery that we can find at the dorsum
of the foot or the top part of our foot.
So these are very important pulse points to know, especially if you are going into any
health care related field.
So first we're going to start talking about the blood vessels within the thorax, specifically
the blood vessels coming from the heart.
We have the aorta, one of the largest arteries in the body.
We have different parts of the aorta.
The first part of the aorta is the ascending aorta.
The ascending aorta arises from the left ventricle.
So blood coming from the left ventricle has to go through the aortic semilunar valve to
be transported to this first part of the aorta, which is the ascending aorta.
Now the ascending aorta is important because we have branches of our coronary arteries coming
from this first section and the coronary arteries provide blood supply to the heart itself.
From the ascending aorta it becomes the aortic arch.
The aortic arch lies posterior to the menubrium of the sternum and has three very important
branches.
The first branch I usually like to call it the right brachiocephalic trunk.
The right brachiocephalic trunk because it gives blood supply to the right side of the
head neck as well as the right upper limb.
So the right brachiocephalic trunk is the first branch and eventually it will branch
off to form the right common carotid artery as well as the right subclavian artery.
And again giving blood supply to the right side of the head neck and the right upper
limb.
The second branch is the left common carotid artery.
So the left common carotid artery would give blood supply eventually to the left side of
the head neck.
The third branch coming off of the aortic arch is the left subclavian artery.
The left subclavian artery will then give blood supply to the left upper limb.
And here is a diagram of the heart showing the aorta which is the largest artery in the
body.
And the first part being the ascending artery and we can see here the branches of the ascending
artery we have the right coronary artery going through that coronary sulcus and then kind
of going posterior to the pulmonary trunk we have the left coronary artery and its two
branches the left anterior descending artery and the circumflex artery here.
The ascending aorta will then become the aortic arch with its three branches we have the right
brachiocephalic trunk the left common carotid artery and the left subclavian artery.
The descending aorta is the section of the aorta after the aortic arch continues from
the aortic arch and it is also synonymous with the thoracic aorta in the thorax.
So the thoracic aorta is in the region of T5 to T12 so vertebrae T5 to T12.
Once it goes through the diaphragm again that muscle that separates the thorax from the
abdomen it becomes the abdominal aorta.
The abdominal aorta will end at L4.
At L4 the abdominal aorta will then divide or bifurcate into right and left common iliac
arteries.
So that is the basic structure of the aorta coming from the heart specifically the left
ventricle of the heart.
We will then get into the arteries of the head neck.
We have pairs of arteries supplying the head neck.
We have the carotid arteries which are branches of the aortic arch.
The right common carotid artery coming from the right brachiocephalic trunk and then the
left common carotid artery coming from as the second branch off of the aortic arch.
And then we also have branches of the subclavian arteries.
We have the vertebral arteries that we talked about when we were going over bones.
These arteries go through the transverse formin within the transverse processes of the cervical
vertebrae.
We also have branches of the subclavian arteries that include the thyroservical trunk giving
blood supply to the neck region around the thyroid gland and the costo cervical trunk
which we will see in the next diagram.
So here are arteries of the head neck.
We see branches of the subclavian artery.
We have the vertebral artery again going through the transverse formin of the cervical vertebrae
which will eventually go into the base of the skull to help contribute to the circle
of willis.
We have the thyroservical trunk and the costo cervical trunk again giving blood supply to
the head and neck.
We can see that the common carotid artery will eventually branch to form the external
carotid artery as well as the internal carotid artery again going into that carotid canal
in the base of the skull to help contribute to the circle of willis which is the blood
supply of the brain.
The common carotid arteries are located in the anterior triangle of the neck.
The two branches of the common carotid artery that we talked about are the external carotid
artery as well as the internal carotid artery.
We have right and left common carotid arteries as well as right and left external internal
carotid arteries.
Here are the branches of the external carotid artery giving blood supply to the external
part of the head and neck.
We have the superior thyroid artery, the lingual artery, facial artery, occipital artery, posterior
erycular, posterior erycular behind the ear.
Superficial temporal artery, that's one artery that we can find at the temple of the head
around the frontal bone where we can palpate a pulse point.
Also an important artery because when we do one of those sliding thermometers it kind
of goes over that superficial temporal artery to give a temperature of a patient and then
the maxillary artery.
The internal carotid artery has the ophthalmic artery giving blood supply to the eye's internal
and anterior cerebral artery giving blood supply to the anterior part of the brain.
Anterior communicating artery help form the cerebral arterial circle or the circle of
willis and the middle cerebral artery.
So that's it for the carotid arteries, the subclavian arteries.
We know that the right subclavian artery originates from the brachiosophallic trunk.
The left subclavian artery is the third branch off of the aortic arch.
The vertebral arteries, a branch of the subclavian artery, supplies the posterior brain.
The vertebral arteries will join to form the basilar artery.
The basilar artery will then divide into two posterior cerebral arteries and then join
to form the posterior communicating arteries that connect the posterior cerebral arteries
to the middle cerebral arteries.
These arteries contributing to the circle of willis which we'll see in the next slide.
So here we see the circle of willis.
The circle of willis we can see the two vertebral arteries coming up from the cervical vertebrae.
They will join together to form this basilar artery here which will then kind of bifurcate
to form the posterior cerebral arteries giving blood supply to the posterior part of the
brain.
And then coming off the posterior cerebral arteries are the posterior communicating arteries
which will join with the internal crowded artery here and then form the anterior cerebral
artery here going towards the anterior part of the brain.
And then between the anterior cerebral artery we have an anterior communicating artery.
So these arteries forming that circle of willis also known as the cerebral arterial circle
giving blood supply to the different parts of the brain.
So with regards to branches of the subclavian artery we have the thyroid cervical trunk.
These send two branches posteriorly over the scapula sends one branch anteriorly to the
inferior part of the thyroid gland which is located in the anterior part of the neck.
The cost of cervical trunk sends a branch superiorly to the deep muscles of the neck.
Also will send a branch inferiorly to the intercosto spaces.
So that is the blood supply to the going to the head and neck.
Now we're going to talk about the arteries of the thorax.
We have the internal thoracic arteries that supply the anterior thoracic walls.
We have the anterior intercostal arteries.
So intercostal means between the ribs.
These are branches of the internal thoracic arteries and we have posterior intercostal arteries
giving blood supply to the inferior nine pairs, I'm sorry not giving blood supply but the
inferior nine pairs will arise from the thoracic aorta.
So moving on to the arteries of the upper limb.
The subclavian artery.
On the right the subclavian artery is a branch of the right brachusophilic trunk.
On the left the subclavian artery is a direct branch coming off of the aortic arch.
It's the third branch.
So the subclavian artery will enter the axilla as the axillary artery.
So a border that I like to use to kind of help you determine when the subclavian artery
turns into the axillary artery is the inferior border of the first rib.
So once the subclavian artery passes by the inferior border of the first rib it becomes
the axillary artery which you'll find basically in your armpit area.
The axillary artery becomes the brachial artery at the inferior border of terries major.
Terries major is a muscle in the back.
So that forms the border between the axillary artery and the brachial artery.
So once the axillary artery passes that inferior border of terries major it becomes the brachial
artery.
The brachial artery will then divide into the radial artery laterally and the ulnar artery
medially.
So here we see that subclavian artery coming from the right brachusophilic trunk.
It'll pass by the inferior border of the first rib become the axillary artery.
Once the axillary artery passes that inferior border of the terries major muscle it will
then become the brachial artery.
So here's that brachial artery.
The brachial artery will then bifurcate to form the radial artery which is located laterally
to the arm and then the ulnar artery which is located medially.
Again that radial artery is an important pulse point so we can get the heart rate located
at the base of the thumb.
And then the radial and ulnar artery will then kind of form this arch giving blood supply
to the hand.
So we have a deep polymer arch as well as a superficial polymer arch and the digital
arteries will come off those arches giving blood supply to the fingers of the hand.
So now that we've talked about the arteries and the arterial supply of the thorax, the
head, neck and the upper limb we're going to talk about the veins.
So with regards to systemic veins we have three major veins that enter the right atrium.
We talked about the superior vena cava, the inferior vena cava as well as the coronary
sinus, the coronary sinus of course draining deoxygenated blood from the heart itself.
Now all medium and large arteries have deep locations accompanied by deep veins.
And then the superficial veins will lie just beneath the skin.
We'll have multivain bundles also known as venous plexuses.
And also we have unusual patterns of venous drainage that we can find in the dural sinuses
as well as the hepatic portal system.
So major veins we have the superior vena cava that returns blood from body regions superior
to the diaphragm.
We have the inferior vena cava that returns blood from the body regions below or inferior
And the superior and inferior vena cava will drain all their blood into that first chamber
on the right side of the heart which is the right atrium.
And here we see the major veins of the systemic circulation.
Remember all these veins are draining blood away from the limbs going back towards the
heart.
So we have our veins of the lower limb going up the leg, going up the iliac veins, the
common iliac veins, abdominal which is the inferior vena cava, going through hepatic
circulation or hepatic portal system.
Also the veins draining from the upper limbs and also the dural venous sinuses and draining
into the veins of the head and neck all going into the superior vena cava.
And we'll break this down into the different regions.
So with regards to the veins of the head and neck we have within the brain the dural sinuses.
Major veins of the dural sinuses include the superior and inferior sagittal sinuses, the
straight sinus, the transverse sinuses and the sigmoid sinuses.
So all these sinuses are draining blood away from the brain.
And most of these are located within the dural matter which is the outermost, makes up the
outermost of the meninges that cover the brain.
So here we can see that superior sagittal sinus, obviously sitting within that sagittal
plane.
We have the inferior sagittal sinus, we have the cavernous sinus, the straight sinus.
We have our transverse sinuses, cavernous sinus located here.
We have a confluence of sinuses, so joining together of sinuses.
And then all these sinuses will then drain into the internal jugular vein that passes
through the jugular form and located at the base of the skull.
So the internal jugular vein will then eventually drain into and join up with the subclavian
vein to then form the brachiosophallic vein.
So the internal jugular vein's drain blood from the brain, superiorly it lies lateral
to the internal carotid artery, inferiorly it will lie lateral to the common carotid artery.
The external jugular veins are tributaries that drain the scalp and again will empty
into the subclavian vein.
If you actually look at an anterior view of the neck, we'll see that the external jugular
vein is more lateral compared to the medially located internal jugular vein.
So here we see veins of the head and neck.
We can see the external jugular vein draining blood from the scalp as well as structures
of the face.
We can see the internal jugular vein draining the dural sinuses of the brain.
And then these, the external jugular vein and the internal jugular vein will then meet
up with the, I'm sorry, the external jugular vein here drains into the subclavian vein and
we see branches of the internal jugular vein that will then join up with the subclavian
vein to form the brachiosophilic vein.
Also we'll see a vertebral brain that accompanies the vertebral artery going through the transverse
form and of the transverse processes of the cervical vertebrae.
Okay.
So all these structures draining the deoxygenia blood of the head and neck, the external jugular
vein draining directly into subclavian vein, the internal jugular vein meeting up with the
subclavian vein to form the brachiosophilic vein which will then drain into the superior
vena cava.
Veins of the thorax draining the thoracic structures include the zygos vein, the hemizygos vein
as well as the accessory hemizygos vein.
Now veins of the upper limbs, the deep veins will follow the path of the companion arteries
and we'll have the same names as the companion arteries.
Superficial veins are visible beneath the skin and this includes the syphallic vein,
bacilic vein, the median cubital vein and the median vein of the forearm.
So here we see a diagram of the veins, both of the thorax and upper limb.
So within the thorax we can see the zygos vein here draining into the superior vena cava.
We have our hemizygos vein located here with the thorax as well as our accessory hemizygos veins.
Again, anything above the diaphragm draining usually into the superior vena cava.
Now we see the internal jugular vein, that larger, more medial vein and then the external
jugular vein, external jugular vein draining into the subclavian vein directly and then
the internal jugular vein will join with the subclavian vein to form the abrasive phallic
veins.
Now let's start distally and go proximately.
So veins of the hand, we have our digital veins which will drain into the superficial
and palmar venous arch, we also have a deep palmar venous arch.
More, the deeper veins include the radial vein located laterally along the radius and
then we have the ulnar vein located along more medially along the ulna.
So veins that we'll see, more laterally we have the syphallic vein here and then more
medially we have the bacilic vein here and then we have that median vein of the forearm
located here, the median vein of the forearm will drain into the bacilic vein and then
we have a communication.
This median cubital vein within our elbow, our cubal fossa, this vein is very important
because we use this vein to do our blood draws or we can even administer intravenous fluids.
So again the syphallic vein will actually travel more laterally, it travels through this sort
of groove between the deltoid and the pectoralis muscle and then more, so that's more laterally.
More medially we'll have the bacilic vein, the brachial vein that accompanies the brachial
artery will actually join into the bacilic vein and then the bacilic vein and the syphallic
vein will form the subclavian vein which will then drain into the brachia syphallic vein
and then the superior vena cava and then back to the right atrium.
So superficial veins form anastomosis frequently, again we have that median cubital vein which
is used for blood draws, so obtained blood or administer intravenous fluids, IV fluids.
When I taught medical assisting, I had to teach my students how to do blood draws and
how to palpate that median cubital vein and you can actually see when we put up a place
with a tourniquet, we can see the veins within that cubital fossa, and there are different
variations of the median cubital vein.
So once the tourniquet is placed properly, this allows for the pooling of blood within
the veins to allow them to kind of pop out and allow us to do our blood draws.
So we have that medial cubital vein within that cubital fossa, more laterally will be
the syphallic vein and then more immediately will be the bacilic vein.
So we can see a surface view of the right upper limb and then cadaver section, again
will have that medial cubital vein within the cubital fossa and then more laterally will
be the syphallic vein and more immediately will be the bacilic vein here.
And those are the, that's the blood supply and the blood vessels of the thorax, the
head neck and the upper limb.